so donald trump's press secretary kaylee
mckennany has uh humiliated herself
again
maybe for the last time if fox news
stops having her on
although my sense is she'll still
continue humiliating herself for a
couple more months
kaylee mckennany does this thing which
is completely
absurd it's absurd in like an evil
genius way
which is she has different personas
sometimes kaylee mckennany is white
house press secretary speaking in her
official role as white house press
secretary
sometimes she is a trump campaign
senior advisor and then sometimes she's
just a private person
and uh i i know that this may be
difficult for a lot of folks
who expect logic and reason to
understand but when kaylee does her
press briefings which she hasn't done in
a very long time
that's very clear she is white house
press secretary
very clear-cut speaking to us as the
representative for donald trump
now just before the election she started
appearing on fox news
pretty frequently under a different
title
and you would see under her name it
would say trump 2020
senior advisor it's already weird
because she's
officially a white house staffer and
then last week
at that completely ridiculous press
conference where she said it was all
stolen
biden didn't win anything trump won
everything and held up pieces of paper
she said hi i'm kaylee mckennany i'm
here in my
personal capacity it's like dr jekyll
and mr hyde
that that sort of thing well this
morning kaylee shows up on fox news and
you just have to see this first of all
i guess in order to try to keep things
kosher from the standpoint of the hatch
act
brian kilmeade actually says kaylee has
two roles
and today she's here not as press
secretary but as a campaign person take
a look
kaylee mcinanny joins us she's got a
dual role here she's on as the trump
2020 campaign advisor uh kate so it's
it's almost like
brian kilmeade was told make sure to
mention this
and you i mean i i don't know how you
tell the difference maybe when she wears
her diamond
cross necklace she's there as press
secretary and when she wears her gold
cross necklace that's when she's the
campaign advisor sort of like superman
when he has the glasses on it's clark
kent when the glasses come off it's
superman i don't know but it's all
wacky but then this is where it gets
just beyond
satire brian kilmeade says you know
joe biden isn't getting the presidential
daily briefing
uh he did win it's a national security
issue
and kaylee says now that's a question
for the white house
she is the white house spokesperson as
press secretary but today we have to
pretend she's a different character
she's merely a lowly campaign advisor
check this out it's wild
a republican he said listen give joe
biden the presidential daily brief
after all senator harris gets gets she's
on the intel committee she's getting
she has high high level security access
has the president consider that
i haven't spoken to the president about
that that would be a question
more for the white house but i will say
that all laws are being followed
with regard to an expected um transition
though we expect to continue on
as the trump administration we will see
how our litigation goes
when we say um how stupid do they think
we are
they think their followers and fox news
viewers
are very stupid and this is
indistinguishable
from parody and even though we've
already heard
that trump knows he can't win and he's
doing this entire thing as
theater and you know taking money from
people in doing so
kaylee mckennany will not close the door
on donald trump pushing for republican
legislators
to try to essentially invalidate the
election results by selecting
trump electors this is the electoral
college strategy we talked about about
six weeks ago
and the idea is take a state that biden
won by the popular vote like for example
wisconsin because biden won
what they're supposed to do is send
biden electors
uh to cast their official electoral
votes for joe biden but if you can
find a state with a state legislature
that is republican that might be willing
to just interfere
theoretically the state legislature
could send trump electors
even though joe biden wins the popular
vote in that state that's what they're
asking about here and kaylee mckinnon he
won't rule it out
controlled state legislatures would then
because they would not be certified
would then appoint pro-trump electors
who would swing the electoral college in
his favor
it's unclear exactly how seriously the
campaign is taking that
how seriously is the campaign
considering that
well constitutionally that is an
accurate argument it is the state
legislatures that choose the electors
but right now
uh they're zeroed in completely on
litigation
and so there she is not ruling it out
but we we might discuss that more
i've already talked about it uh and and
of course
no good trump voter fraud segment
would be complete until somebody holds
up papers for the camera
and kaylee mckennany also doing that fix
their ballot so we have a number of
affidavits
from voters who were not told to fix
their ballot while their democrat
counterparts in seven counties
were so that's kaylee mckennany uh trump
campaign staffer
not there yeah i know you i know she's
white house press secretary
she wasn't there as white house press
secretary so when she was asked
questions about trump
that she doesn't want to answer she says
oh that would be a question for the
white house like maybe
for the white house press secretary
which is her
these are wild times that we are living
through
i am very ready for it to end and we're
getting closer we're getting closer and
even donald trump seems to be
acknowledging that
this episode is sponsored by blue chew
one of the things i make a priority on
the show
is not to perpetuate stigma for things
that don't deserve it we've talked about
mental health we've talked about many
things where we should all just be
respectful adults period and we would be
better off
and blue chew can increase performance
and give you that extra confidence you
may be looking for bluetooth.com
blue like the color blue is the first
chewable
with the same fda approved ingredient as
in viagra
and cialis it can be taken day or night
even on a full stomach since it's
chewable
blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed doctors you don't have to go to
a doctor's office
you don't have to wait in line at a
pharmacy it ships right to your door
in a discreet package they're made in
the usa
and since bluechew prepares and ships
direct
it's cheaper than a pharmacy and best of
all
no more awkwardness we've got a special
deal for our viewers and listeners go to
bluetooth.com
get your first shipment free when you
use our
promo code pacman that's p-a-k-m-a-n
pages five dollars shipping that's
b-l-u-e
chew.com promo code pacman to try it
totally free
bluechu is the better cheaper faster
choice
and we thank them for sponsoring the
david pakman show